Kris Kobach is the secretary of state of
Kansas and he joins us tonight mr. kobak
Thanks going up great to be with you
tucker so well I just want to be totally
clear on this because and I again I hate
because I really think people ought to
have a chance to respond to what you say
about them I'm sorry the Alderman's not
here but we had a long conversation with
him last night he told us three times he
said look I'm an expert on electoral law
in the state of Illinois you have to
prove you're a citizen of the country in
order to register to vote is that true
that is false anyone who studies this
issue knows there are only four states
where the laws require you to provide
proof of citizenship when you registered
about in those states Arkansas Arizona
Alabama and Georgia and of those four
only Kansas in Arizona have fully
implemented the law the other two states
are in the process of starting to
implement so just to be clear what you
do need in every state is a government
idea of universally recognized ID and
that's the one thing it's kind of hard
for illegal aliens to get because
they're not supposed to be here so when
government gives them an ID that is
sufficient for voter registration how
are they not abetting voter fraud well
yeah it is absolutely abetting voter
fraud and you know the amazing thing is
of course in the other 46 states you
don't need to provide proof of
citizenship all you need to do is check
a box that says I am a US citizen and we
have found hundreds of cases all over
the country we've had expert witnesses
look at Kansas and it could be as high
as 18,000 aliens on our voter rolls and
in other states it's probably in the six
figures or more but the point is people
are doing this all the time sometimes
intentionally sometimes the non-citizens
are doing it unintentionally they can't
even read what it is they they've just
signed or they didn't pay attention to
it and then they start getting mail from
the candidates saying hey you're a
registered voter don't forget to vote
for me and don't forget to vote on
August 7th or whatever the date is so if
they're registering and they're voting
but why wouldn't that make a difference
in election let me clear the Democratic
Party is abetting this or doing this on
purpose they're printing these IDs if
government expense public expense giving
them to illegals and letting them
register to vote I mean why is this not
an electoral strategy it looks like that
it certainly looks that way and it does
seem that
that many in the Democrat Party
hopefully not all seem to think that
it's okay if aliens vote and yeah maybe
they shouldn't be but heck it helps the
Democrat Party anyway some of them have
talked like that and I think it's
appalling look we should all the
Americans are allowed to vote in these
elections you win or lose by persuading
Americans but your policies are right
the idea that you would try to replace
or over outweigh American voters by
bringing in foreign voters is outrageous
yeah that's the foreign influence
scandal so you're in the middle of a
lawsuit over something related to this
yeah yeah so the ACLU has kind of
declared war on election security laws
like ours and Kansas and this this war
is something that is outrageous they're
making ridiculous arguments like it's an
unconstitutional burden for you to reach
into your file cabinet at home and find
your birth certificate or they're
claiming that the National motor voter
law of 1993 somehow created a special
privilege if you get your license at the
DMV you don't have to prove citizenship
even though the law doesn't say that so
they're crazy arguments but we're
fighting them in court next week yeah
well I hope it's really clear to our
audience what the point of all this is
because it is clear I'm a secretary
thank you for coming on I appreciate it
my pleasure
acting ice director Thomas Holman spoke
frankly about what Oakland Mayor Libby
Schaaf did when she warned of the
impending raids in her City watch what
she did is no better than a you know a
gang look out yelling police when I when
a police cruiser comes in the
neighborhood except she did it the
entire community I mean it's beyond the
pale I've been I've been doing this for
34 years and this is a whole new law to
intentionally warn criminals that law
enforcement coming